s'il vous allez bien ça va super bien
d'ailleurs il ya peu de temps vous êtes
parti à marrakech ouais c'est vrai je
vois sur votre petit 1 à l'est eh bien
j'ai des images non marrakech diffusé
des images de tout je suis partout alors
vous avez encore il faut corriger on
dirait qu'à la mecque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après kung fu oui avec vous aviez un
casting cinq étoiles
il y avait 10 1 jean michel et kelly oui
que ce soit sur le plateau de ppp ou
dans un autre pays ou encore à dos de
chameau eh bien chacun reste comme il
est et ça c'est rassurant tout de suite
et si mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fabien lecoeuvre données petit chameau
c'est normal qu'ils m'ont chauveau qui
vous fait que c'est tellement mignon
nous avons d'ailleurs
thébaux cyril la durée lawrence d'arabie
dans les séries les majestueux riahi
tiennent une main l'autre main sur la
cuisse c'est vraiment la classe
[Musique]
mais ta gueule
j'aime ta vu les plombs berges et bien
je vais bien je vais aussi aller le vert
c'est une belle que tu aimes bien la
couleur le vert
c'est jésus c'est jésus jésus super
suivez le il va faire des miracles je
viens et le vieil des baux les bourgs où
les quoi photo il ya eu bien sûr
lunettes
les créations de là avec une est cool
c'est en partie sa web d'accord merci
alors on a été très bien accueilli je
voulais remercier des équipes de la ram
ainsi que le directeur de l'office
national des aéroports
un grand merci à nejma pour les
activités pour la sequenza mot merci
alexis roule et sylvia roule bien sûr
pour nous avoir accueilli au palais
roule et merci au restaurant la le
tongien
on a très bien manger là bas vous avez
votre chaussure marrakech bien sûr alors
isabelle comment le vin va très bien et
bien ou si vous êtes une femme de
lettres qui a beaucoup de vocabulaire on
peut avoir plus de retour pour entendre
pour que vous vous mettrez on dirait
qu'on est dans un taxi derrière n'entend
pas très bien c'est que vous êtes une
femme de lettres sauf quand vous êtes
impressionné et oui là vous n'avez que
plus que deux mots à la bouche
c'est une vraie reine attise qu'on
entend c'est la taupe or de le capter la
zombie de l'ocab
[Musique]
le tableau il est splendide et alors là
la statue là moi je suis une fanatique
des bons moi qui le suis une fanatique
de cette époque parce qu'en plus de rien
ta niche une thématique des arbres très
très très beau qu'est ce que c'est beau
aussi qu'est ce que c'est magnifique
qu'est ce que c'est bon par une sorte de
jardin d'hiver
qu'est ce que ce mot qui se dévouent
magnifique tweed
qu est ce si beau ça magnifique audi
dans a pu même est où c'est magnifique
qu'est ce que c'est bon tout tout est
magnifique c'est pas comme si j'allais
c'est pas croyable tout est magnifique
tout était magnifique ça alors ça c'est
la boucle obligatoire réseau à chaque
fois voilà ils ont fait une boucle voila
voila c'est très bien on a d'autres
choses bouclées
oui un cyril mois la belge fonçait qu'au
maroc on parlait un ravin bah ouais mais
a priori la hchouma je me suis trompé
d'endroit va jusque dans la langue
officielle dans le désert pour tp family
mais ça reste verlan ah ouais oui on
regarde c'est quoi le bailleur elle
apporte à l'éthique peut donc c'est la
taupe or de leucate c'est la zone b2 le
cadre ou quoi ben laden chez nous c'est
ouf
et c'est le début d'un muffin ça tu vois
il veut vraiment évolué moins que true
blood chez moi tu tiens pull sylla et ut
saut tu t'en ben ali on devrait faire
une ce combat de chameau c'est vrai
qu'il est avec multiplie les tisons
qu'elle comprend ce qu'il sait faire
[Applaudissements]
cette boucle
alors pour lui envient bien sûr pas
question d'aller au maroc sans assister
un petit show des magnifiques danseuses
et un salon cherche on me taxe est fait
plaisir
[Musique]
dans ses spectacles et dans ce cas voilà
c'est la plate forme d'un dvr
[Musique]
bâle est le même en ont dû bricoler
belle mais la joueuse belge on gagne les
la jambe
et avec sa récente à ce niveau
j'ai peur que sa poche le personnel
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui ce que vous savez que mamie zaza est
une héroïne mais oui elle a des super
pouvoirs
non elle peut s'endormir n'importe où ça
les téléspectateurs aiment bien ça la
vie
[Musique]
et
maman
[Musique]
j'ai poussé ma nuit passé 48 heures sans
dormir et 48 ans également sentir la
chair il y aura d'autres choses de pukki
en plateau dans un instant avec deux
personnes qui ne s'entendent pas du tout
dans les chroniqueurs vous dis je ne
croyais pas ça et il ya deux personnes
outre qui sait la guerre ou pas la
guerre alors apathique mais il ya une
petite guerre entre deux chroniqueurs
vous verrez ça dans un instant à toute
une équipe ou qui louent balance tout ce
qui se passe dans touche pas à mon poste
est clair et apparemment pour qui il ya
deux personnes qui on croit qu'ils
s'aiment bien et en fait c'est pas la
folie entre les deux ah c'est pas
vraiment ça on va dire que c'est un
nouveau binôme
ouais il s'agit de isa et bernard et
comme je disais tout à l'heure qu'ils ne
s'entendent pas c'est un double sens et
oui ils ne s'entendent vraiment vraiment
il
je ne me parle pas je croyais sculpté
dit
le chemin devant nous
[Musique]
kenny
je prends que les gens
la faute à quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
c'est toi quand on jamais ce que chez
marc mode il ya du bruit en plus de lire
quoi comment ça il pleut on a boat show
oui place à mon sujet préféré quoi vous
s'il est bien sévère et même d'enfants
et comme tous les enfants encadrés ont
été vos petits camarades
en fait c'est ça des kamas métaux par
vous transformez le plateau en cours de
récré si c'est vrai ce qui motive les
chanteuses gueule ta gueule
fabien tu te mets là bas bordel
[Musique]
mais si joseph voilà un nouveau couple
qui bat de l aile dans le monde
merveilleux
jamais un cours qui battait matters peu
val de l'aisne n'est pas beaucoup plus
[Musique]
c'est toi qui pue du cul c'est toi
calme toi
maintenant
quand on tue il ya des olives
[Musique]
m
moi qui a lancé cette créature
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand vous voyez comme ça
maintenant avec un peu de recul quand
vous voyez vous je vous habitez vous
distraire voilà annoncé vous vous
distraire
j'ai trouvé ça mignon pour une fois
c'est mécanique de la mécanique du doigt
j'aime bien le fait très bien
je vois des meilleurs championnats du
monde la défense mais combien d'enfants
de 2 à faire un petit tour du côté de st
jean be quoi ça vous dit d'aller faire
un petit tour du côté de chez les
directions son canapé homogène et pop
comme chez papy c'est parti chinois
[Musique]
[ __ ] avait pêché un autre mec
de la roue de l'a22 loi cela recevoir de
la recevoir approché orthophoniste
donc tu bats merci et un triple maillot
[Applaudissements]
c'est en coupe et qui doit et paca
qu'une danseuse avec mini non
[Rires]
photo
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai c'est vraiment le mouloudia
qui s'enlève à chanter je sais mais
c'est pour sao paulo il n'y a pas le feu
au lac
oui alors la bulle eric naulleau s'est
bien intégré à l'équipe ouais ouais mais
la paix lots de la bande
elle peut même quelques petites ruses
belle c'est sûr que pour lui on est bien
loin de dj
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma mère elle d'apprendre que mon père et
son frère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
las
j'ai dîné avec m universitaire y a pas
du tout de mettre universitaires non à m
university personnes oui mais c'est qui
je le crois qu'il fait on quand tu fais
ta maîtrise normalement tu as un maître
universitaire j'ai fait une maîtrise ou
bah oui que tu maîtrises histoire
martiaux du loup comment la la presse
allemande et française enlevées que la
naissance de l'aiglon c'était mon ma
thèse bah ouais vous voyez qui s'est
déclenché l'aiglon bien sûr dans un lac
des endormis dans l'équipe sa famille
comme dans la série game of thrones tout
le monde se bat pour avoir la couronne
du roi des failles ou et cette semaine
vu que on vient d'avoir bien contre
toute attente c'est une règle qui a
livré les bobos nord et moi et ils
peuvent être jugés ce qu'il s'agit
ouais j'espère un orient
[Musique]
ça passe l'émission mathis l'animateur
etc
jeux gourmands de tous de l'avis de vous
de tous bords
[Applaudissements]
évidemment forme
merci
les enfants comprennent pas encore en
forme
si valérie merci poquet pas vu que les
absents ont toujours tort et je suis
très triste parce qu'aujourd'hui alors
il est un petit peu souffrant matthieu
delormeau
non mais là ils ont une angine oui là il
a passé il a dormi tout nuire
malheureusement j'ai l'impression qu'il
me fut pour consoler du coup obligé de
passer cet extrait c'est quoi nadine
regarder ça va vous intéresser
non
[Musique]
bizarre
l'air
hier
les b n'est pas le mien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez un petit dernier match et
richelieu on s'en bat l'oeil voilà tout
ce qu'on vous dit je crois dont on se
fout c'est ça exactement c'est ça
faisait de belles discussions et moi je
n'arrête pas d'être une d'animaux
les
[Musique]
enfin complet je range derrière
on sent
[Applaudissements]